Blackbeard might have a Mythical Zoan fruit
and by the series’ end his powers might be
so broken that he can control the seas
themselves.
Big spoiler warning if you haven’t caught up with
the manga yet, but the last few chapters of One
Piece were a complete game changer and that’s
putting it lightly. Go ahead and click off the
video and spend some quality time on VIZ if you’re
not there yet. We’ll see you back here soon!
Today we’re making the bittersweet decision that
it might be time to retire some of our favorite
Blackbeard devil fruit theories from throughout
the years. Goodbye to Cerberus. Goodbye to the
three brothers. Goodbye, even, to the Kraken.
Because given the big reveal of Luffy’s zoan
devil fruit a much more interesting option
has now opened up: That Teach has potentially
also has eaten a mythical zoan: the Hito
Hito no Mi - Model “Moon God” … Blank…
Really the jury’s still out on what Oda
is going to call this one. There’s no
telling what Oda will decide to name
the Moon God of the One Piece world,
but since Sun God Nika is an original creation
and not directly borrowed from any mythology,
it’s unlikely we’ll see a Tsukuyomi or Artemis
fruit anytime soon. Instead, Blackbeard’s fruit
will probably also be based on a God unique to
One Piece, merging different cultural ideas.
What’s up, I’m Manu and today we’re talking about
Marshall D. Teach and the secret
identity of the Yami Yami no Mi.
I mean, for years and years we’ve theorized about
what Blackbeard’s zoan will be. There are so many
threes associated with Teach - his three pistols,
the three skulls on his flag, the three claws on
the weapon that he used to scar Shanks. Naturally,
he’d have three devil fruits, too - a logia,
the Yami Yami no Mi - a paramecia, the Gura
Gura no Mi - and a to-be-determined zoan fruit.
We thought for sure that this was hinting
toward a Cerberus with its three heads or
a Kraken with its three hearts. And
while those are still possibilities,
we have to welcome a new theory to the club.
So why do we suddenly think that he
actually has a Moon God fruit? Well,
because Luffy has the Sun God fruit, of course!
Luffy and Blackbeard have always been opposites.
Throughout the story, they have always paralleled
and mirrored one another. If Luffy is the sun, as
you will see, it only makes sense that Blackbeard
is the moon, the two most common reoccurring
symbols in the story! If you need a little
further convincing, though, here are just a few
ways that these two characters counter each other:
First, their powers rival each other perfectly.
Luffy is made of rubber which can insulate
against the earthquakes that Blackbeard can
produce. Even though the quake-quake fruit
is considered the strongest paramecia
with enough power to destroy the world,
Luffy has a built in immunity against it just
like he did with Eneru’s lightning fruit.
And now, if Luffy’s a Sun God which
could explain his strange ability
to produce flames, this runs counter to
Blackbeard’s darkness-darkness fruit.
Those flames are literally
light against the darkness.
It’s not just their powers that are
opposites, though. Their parallels run
much deeper than that and are ingrained
in their character traits. Luffy is the
Warrior of Liberation - he brings
freedom to the people he meets on
every island. However, Blackbeard leaves a path
of devastation behind him wherever he goes.
We first learned about Blackbeard on Drum
Island - he and his crew scared off Wapol
and his legion of doctors, but also left
the villagers in fear and turmoil. However,
after the Straw Hats visit Drum Island, they
liberate the people from Wapol’s oppressive rule.
They also acquired one bonus
cotton-candy loving reindeer mascot!
We also see Luffy and Blackbeard as opposites
in the ways they attract their crew mates.
Luffy and Blackbeard both brought freedom to
their crew in a sense. Zoro was literally released
from a stockade, Nami from Arlong’s clutches,
and Robin from the likes of Crocodile and later
CP9. However, even the Straw Hats that weren’t
freed from literal imprisonment were freed from a
figurative prison. Usopp, Sanji, and many
others were lifted from their ordinary
lives and obligations. Luffy enabled them to
travel the world in pursuit of their dreams.
Luffy gathers his strength from his
crewmates and depends on them, but
also allows them to chase their own
goals and find their own sense of
fulfillment. On the other hand, Blackbeard
frees many of his crewmates from Impel Down,
but it’s so they can serve his interests -
not so they can live out their own dreams…
...which for most of the Level 5
prisoners, you know, is probably
just murder actually…so maybe Pizarro does
feel a deep sense of fulfillment after all.
Even the ways Luffy and Blackbeard
received their fruits are opposites.
The Hito Hito no Mi: Model Nika almost seemed to
seek out Luffy specifically. The Gorosei describe
it evading the World Government for 800 years,
as if the fruit has a will of its own. It seems
like Luffy was chosen by the fruit to carry
on the will of Joyboy and the Sun God Nika.
Contrast this with Blackbeard who was on the
hunt for the Yami Yami no Mi and murdered his
crewmate Thatch in order to obtain its power.
He also killed Whitebeard in order to take
his fruit as well. He wasn’t chosen by his
fruit - he sought out his fruit at any cost.
Luffy just innocently taking a bit out of Shanks’
treasure just doesn’t give the same vibe as cold
blooded killing. I’d go as far as to say
they give off the opposite vibe, actually.
In so many ways, Luffy and Blackbeard
are diametrically opposed. They are
direct opposites. Therefore, if Luffy is the sun,
it makes sense that Blackbeard would be the moon.
Obviously, the moon is important to One
Piece as a whole, too. If the Sun God
Nika fruit was foreshadowed even from the
first chapter being titled Romance Dawn and
from other clues like the Straw Hat’s
ship being called the Thousand Sunny,
then you’d think there would to be a Moon God
fruit, too with how prominent the moon is overall.
Here are just a few of the ways that
the moon features heavily in the series:
Eneru’s entire goal was to sail the Arc Maxim up
to the endless land mass that was “Fairy Vearth.”
And, in Eneru’s cover story we found that not only
are there space pirates kicking it on the moon,
but there are many archaeological clues that
the winged races from the sky islands actually
originally came from the moon. In the library of
Ohara, we see a planetary model that shows the
One Piece world having multiple moons. The minks
transform into their powerful Sulong forms in the
light of the full moon. And, the surnames of the
Wano clans also contain the Kanji for “moon” for
instance, Kozuki means “Light Moon”, Shimotsuki
means “Frost Moon”, and the list just goes on.
The moon isn’t just important
for One Piece as a whole,
either. The moon also seems to hold
special significance for Marshall D.
Teach himself. When Eiichiro Oda drew Blackbeard
as a child, we see him sitting and crying while
a crescent moon hangs in the sky above him.
We also know that Blackbeard never sleeps.
I mean, he really needs to try taking melatonin.
His insomnia might be even worse than mine.
Maybe he, too, is just a coffee lover. Or maybe a
Moon God is naturally active and alert at night?
We’ve established that due to the parallels
between Blackbeard and Luffy, he probably posesses
a Moon God devil fruit. However, what exactly does
that mean? What abilities does a Moon God have?
In the same way you wouldn’t expect a Sun God to
be made of rubber, what can Blackbeard do with
this fruit? Sure, he already has the wildly
strong mastery of earthquakes and darkness,
but in the same way Luffy’s new power is broken -
ruled by his imagination and the boundlessness of
cartoon logic, what borderline unstoppable powers
should we expect from Blackbeard moving forward?
Many people assume that Blackbeard will acquire
a mythical zoan later on, but I think it’s more
likely that, like Luffy, he’s had his mythical
zoan all along. In the same way that what Luffy
thought was the Gomu Gomu no Mi was actually the
Hito Hito no Mi: Model Sun God Nika, Blackbeard’s
darkness darkness fruit might actually the Moon
God fruit. This would play into the opposites once
again - Luffy thought he was a paramecia, but was
a zoan. Well, Blackbeard says he’s a logia, but
is actually a zoan as well. But while Luffy was
totally ignorant of his own fruit and still his,
Blackbeard is fully aware but makes other people
ignorant of the true nature of his abilities.
The Yami Yami no Mi actually being the
Hito Hito no Mi: Model Moon God Blank
…wow, we really need Oda to give
us the name so we know what to call
it…Anyway, the Yami Yami no Mi actually being
the…Moon God fruit… makes a lot of sense.
When Blackbeard fights Ace, Ace actually
comments that Blackbeard’s fruit doesn’t
“feel” like a logia.
Ace would be something of an expert, too,
wielding the Mera Mera no Mi. It makes sense,
too, because Blackbeard doesn’t turn into
or generate darkness - he’s different from
every other logia fruit
user we’ve met in that way.
Instead, the darkness fruit demonstrates
strange powers. He sucks things in with a
power closer to gravity than darkness. He can
negate someone else’s devil fruit powers when
he makes contact with them. Again, not something
that logically makes sense with darkness. He also
amplifies the physical damage that he himself
takes - none of these really make sense for a
darkness-darkness fruit, but could be explained
by mysterious properties of a Moon God fruit.
It’s similar to how some of Luffy’s powers didn’t
make sense for a rubber fruit - generating flames
with Red Hawk, changing directions with the
jet culverin, even things as basic as Gear
2nd and Gear 3rd don’t really make sense
without a heaping helping of anime logic.
But in addition to what Blackbeard can already do,
just like Luffy’s awakening unlocked
a whole host of new abilities,
we’ll probably get some wild new powers once
the truth of Blackbeard’s fruit is revealed.
One of those powers? Hitting the subscribe button.
But what else could a Moon God possibly do? Well,
we know that Oda takes tons of
inspiration from mythologies
around the world. Maybe some of the lunar deities
from across the globe can give us some hints.
The main Egyptian Moon God is Khonsu, but I’ll
leave it to Oscar Isaac to explain that one.
However, the Egyptian God Thoth is also
connected to the moon as well as being a
God of wisdom and knowledge. And while Blackbeard
certainly possesses a lot of secret knowledge,
this doesn’t scream “power-up”. The Greek moon
goddesses, such as Artemis, are often associated
with the hunt. Again, Blackbeard doesn’t seem
connected to hunting or wild animals, but we
do see his crew hunting down powerful devil fruits
like Jesus Burgess did in Dressrosa. Another Greek
Moon God, Selene, has power over illusions -
While not Blackbeard himself, his crew mates
Shiryu and Catarina Devon use illusory powers
in the form of invisibility and shapeshifting.
Across many, many cultures lunar deities are
also connected to childbirth, but I hope for
all of our sakes that Blackbeard’s
power is not connected to that because
Teach is that last person I want
to see in the maternity ward.
Of course, with One Piece being a manga,
we can’t forget about Japanese mythology.
In Shinto, the Moon God Tuskuyomi is set
in conflict against the Sun God Amaterasu.
There’s not much to say about any inspiration
for powers, but it’s worth noting that the
conflict between these two gods originated from
a fight over food. That reminds me quite a bit
of a certain argument between Luffy and
Blackbeard over some Jayan cherry pies.
Of course, I am leaving out one of the
obvious powers associated with the moon,
though. One that’s especially
significant given that One Piece is a
seafaring adventure. The moon’s
gravity controls the tides.
Could the same “gravity” of the
darkness-darkness fruit control the sea itself?
I know, I know: It sounds crazy, since
water is a devil fruit user’s weakness,
but it’s not unheard of for a devil
fruit user to manipulate water
indirectly. While they can’t go
for a swim, we do see Aokiji freeze
massive tidal waves at Marineford and Charlotte
Oven boils the sea around Whole Cake Island.
If Blackbeard could influence tides, then
he could easily sink opposing ships and
have an advantage in combat over other devil
fruit users. He could also make it extremely
difficult to travel to certain islands
- in opposition to Luffy’s liberation,
he’d be literally restricting
people’s freedom of travel.
Could a previous user of the Moon God fruit
- or even the original Moon God itself - be
responsible for phenomena like the calm belt and
the unpredictable weather of the Grand Line? We
know that devil fruit awakenings can leave a
lasting impact on the world’s landscape, just
like how Aokiji and Akainu changed Punk Hazard’s
environment. It would make total sense if a devil
fruit was responsible for the Grand Line itself,
and why not one as powerful as a Moon God fruit?
Since Luffy’s fruit is boundless and
only limited by his own imagination,
he needs a foe that has a similar level
of over-poweredness - breaking the taboo
between devil fruits and water would
be one way for Blackbeard to achieve
a borderline broken ability and make for
a stellar final fight between the two.
Another possibility, aside from control over the
oceans, could have to do with Blackbeard’s ability
to consume multiple fruits. This strange power,
exclusive to Blackbeard, has yet to be explained.
We know that in Jaya, Luffy and Zoro referred
to Blackbeard as “them” as if he had multiple
identities. Does the Moon God act as its own
entity, separate from Teach? Does it have to do
with the gravity of pulling things in? Maybe it’s
yet another opposite of Luffy’s abilities: While
the Sun God gives freedom and empowers others, the
Moon God is able to take in more power for itself.
Now this video mostly talked about Blackbeards
powers, but if you really want to understand who
Teach really is and why he is so important to the
story, you really shouldn’t ignore this next video
here where I explain his entire character and
the three brothers theory as a cherry on top.